then he went Donald Trump you know
Donald Trump I love Donald Trump but no
more dropped by the drop boxes are just
so bad no more drop boxes Dickinson
hologic and Stephanie cephahide
that was about a guy named a rhino named
Mitt Romney Mitt Romney real Beauty I
had to give the American people their
voice back by building something called
truth truth Central he voted against
Kate's law and he voted for Obama
amnesty as you know we've endorsed Dr Oz
we've endorsed
JP right J.D Mandel and he's doing great
I've had more investigations and Jesse
James Billy the could some of the
world's greatest cricket players
from suchin tendulker duviron Kohli as
the great religious teacher Swami Vive
come on what said
I hope they now go and take a look at
the oranges or the oranges of the uh
investigation the beginnings of that
investigation and God bless
the United States thank you very much he
was awarded the broad star and the
combat infantry and badge for his
service we have to keep our country gate
prepared but it's not I mean for some
reason it's just not great anymore if
you care about Law and Order look Law
and Order in normal times roughly 40
percent of fresh vegetables at about 40
percent China nambia's health system is
increasingly self-sufficient this is not
about virtue cycling and signing and the
great General and President Ulysses S
Grant he's done he's really come back a
long way over the last 10 years hasn't
he
appreciate it very much Tim Apple when
they gaze upon your semites your
seminites towering Sequoias they
delivered a Swift and swept in you know
that sweeping it was Swift and it was
sweeping like nobody's
ever seen anything happen units of
plasma for plasma donate plasma into
failing New York Times by
an anonymous really an anonymous gutless
coward I may ask Marilyn Lockheed
the leading
woman's business the teacher should ever
be allowed to teach transgender to our
children while they're parent of himself
no nobody has to have parental consent
and we will totally oppose the Biden
administration at this this
Administration uh he made some
statements rough statements on Jewish
you heard them and you know them well
oh
I love mangoes too
okay now that we are up under our body's
regime my bag of mangoes now costs
[Music]
11.99 that seems like a pretty good deal
a bag of mangoes mango art mangoes
that's it eight or eleven bucks
[Music]
bring my mango
the Wisconsin crowd identified with the
mango
ghostly affected the American people
it's highway robbery is what you doing
mangoes
[Music]
it is day three of CPAC with Deepak so
great to see many of you here again for
the third day in a row oh my God
something is happening very very uh bad
with what's going on behind me let me
let me fix that okay just just give me
okay we are back let's take it from the
top it's so great to see everybody here
today it is day three of CPAC we have
videos we have audios we have memes we
have incompetent people we're going to
be hearing from but the big speakers
today
are coming up momentarily and they will
include
Francis Suarez the mayor of Miami
Viana schlapp who I can only imagine is
related to Matt and Mercedes schlapp I
don't know
um
something about Israel and the Deep
state which sounds very lame but then
the big speeches are Nigel farage the
former leader of the brexit party
propagandist Steve Bannon and of course
2024 Republican presidential candidate
Vivek ramaswamy whose announcement of
his candidacy
shook the political foundations on which
the country is built and irreversibly
changed the trajectory of the Republican
primary as all of you know
none of that is true actually actually
that's not true I do have my cappuccino
let's see
it's probably an eight on the espresso
a seven on the phone we've we've seen
better foam in our day
hmm
perfectly reasonable espresso overall
and as many of you are noticing the vibe
at CPAC this year has been terrible
terrible terrible just humiliating in
every sense of the word let's look at
some clips uh from from
CPAC today
um let's see we will start with what do
we have here
um
Bo bear at CPAC let's see what she had
to say do this we've already had
yeah those were humiliating to
Republicans there are going to be more
we brought in those uh fired Executives
from Twitter thank you by the way who by
the way Executives when you were
grilling them in your mind to some of
those Executives and you can name names
perjure themselves in front of you
Congressman bober I think every one of
them did every one of them perjure
themselves
yes so
we've already had okay the Twitter file
hearings part my mouse just died there
are going to be more we brought in oh
God I can't even hired Executives from
Twitter by the way who by the way
Executives when you were grilling them
in your mind to some of those Executives
and you can name names perjure
themselves in front of you Congressman I
think everyone one of them did every one
of them perjure themselves
yes
all the way over here there are going to
be more we brought in those all right so
everything going wrong I need new
batteries for the wireless mouse all
right so at some point during a break
we'll we'll deal with that okay
um here are people yelling we love Trump
at Nikki Haley while she was trying to
interview
[Music]
I'm too sure
it's Nikki Haley
alright so a lot of pro-trump actions
still going on there here is uh Kimberly
Guilfoyle of course known for one of the
most iconic moments from any Republican
speech we've ever seen let me see where
it is
oh no do I not have it
oh here
let's see what she had to say because
all of us in this room have one message
to Joe Biden it is time to put America
first
to put comments
oh my God there's no one there oh my God
what a pathetic event that line did
really well
with
oh it's so pathetic it's so pathetic
um all right let's see what else we have
from CPAC
um here's Ben Carson they were playing
music to get Ben Carson off their stage
for five minutes but he kept going oh
this I have to see this is so
embarrassing to these people basically
College young staffers what you need to
know about the government so that you
don't have to so that you can hit the
ground running because we need to get
these people in because ninety percent
of the of the career employees are
people who live in this area who have
the policy it's amazing he's completely
unaffected by the fact that they're
playing him off he's he he just doesn't
care he takes in this area who slow
things down who push things forward
we've got to be able to do much better
than that by understanding this process
so that's what the EBA is all about
and this will help us to determine and
answer the question
which Benjamin Franklin said if we can
keep it it's a wonderful system that we
have don't let anybody tell you anything
that's different from that but we're the
ones who are going to have to do it and
if you want to know can we keep it find
a World War II veteran and ask them what
was going through their head and D-Day
when they oh my God shores of Normandy
and all of those people were being shot
and they stepped over those dead bodies
knowing in many cases they would never
see their loved ones or their Homeland
again
why did they do it
they did it for you and me so that we
could live in peace and safety ask them
if you would think I have to bookmark
this for the Monday show this is
unbelievable we can keep it we can with
all of us thank you so much
[Applause]
oh my God all right Dr Ben Carson
um uh a good speech a good solid speech
one that folks seem to enjoy however it
could it's not lost on myself or Tom
basili who joins us right now who's the
host of America right now
um that they were playing the music I
mean they're behind that's not useful
yeah not lost on us oh my God this is
the best thing I've ever seen it is
unbelievable
a comedy of errors going on here
all right let's stand by for the next
thing a couple quick super chats Adam
says thank you for spreading the truth
David sir I come to you with tears in my
eyes it's probably probably allergies ah
yes well
sorry to hear that I want to say thank
you to some great people Angelica Pilger
as well as Jason sigmeyer and Ryan
stinchcomb who have signed up or gifted
memberships on my website joinpakman.com
folks we've got a coupon code it is CPAC
trash CPAC trash is the code use it to
sign up at joinpakman.com if we get to
100 website members and twitch
subscribers phone lines will of course
open over on Twitch thanks to gravyj
recur naria
and then two gifted uh subscriptions
from Sterling Lana that's five plus
three five plus three is I believe that
that's eight
um so I think we are standing by now for
whatever is the next thing I mean who
who even knows let's get back to a
couple more of these clips what you
couldn't you couldn't satirize CPAC any
better than they are doing to themselves
um
Trump unveils his latest scheme to hold
a contest for people who oh this I have
to see but almost one-third of the land
mass of the United States is owned by
the federal government
with just a very very small portion of
that land just a fraction
one half of one percent would you
believe that we should hold a contest to
Charter up to 10 new cities and award
them to the best proposals for
development in other words we'll
actually build new cities in our country
totally reasonable idea
to submit your ideas for a city and
we'll pick 10 and build them dear God
again these Freedom cities will reopen
the frontier Freedom cities reignite
American imagination and give hundreds
of thousands of young people by the way
China has done stuff like this and it
doesn't go particularly well you could
research it people and other people
all hard-working families a new shot at
home ownership and in fluid yeah so
there's a completely wacky idea very
very wacky idea coming from CPAC let's
see what else we have at CPAC here is
Nikki Haley making a declaration Joe and
Conley even say that America's racist
wokeness is a virus more dangerous than
any pandemic hands down is it I have
traveled the world and back how many
people has wokeness killed and I've seen
what's out there America isn't perfect
but the principles at the heart of
America are perfect and take it from me
the first minority female governor in
history
oh 20 speakers denouncing identity
politics and then listen to Nikki Haley
oh my God these people are up these
people are a joke
oh my goodness
we're on day three of attacking identity
politics and Nikki Haley comes out and
touts her identity
oh it's it's unbelievable America is not
a racist country
oh guys why would anyone think America
is racist or sexist I mean listen it
only took
250 years to get a minority female
governor of any of the 50 states right I
mean obviously the country's not racist
or sexist right away after
250 years of this country being a
country
they elected Nikki Haley as the first
minority female governor so there's no
racism there we've you know it it only
took until 2020
to get the first female
president or vice president
that's like quick I mean listen 250 just
boom you got yourself a female vice
president obviously there's nothing
sexist either in the history of this
country
anyway so not going super well I think I
would say
um all right I have uh is this Francis
Suarez the mayor of Miami let's listen
we are expected to make a difference not
a statement we deal in substance not
stunts results not rhetoric
we're expected to deliver to have
answers not anger
when tragedy strikes from hurricanes to
tornadoes to mass violence and turmoil
our people turn to us
we are there to comfort them we are
there to protect them and we are there
to lead them
these are the values that this
conference has defended for decades are
they but sometimes it seems that many of
those who served in Washington dismissed
the role of local elected leadership
in Miami we've embraced a conservative
values of keeping everyone safe keeping
everyone's taxes low and keeping
everyone free to innovate and create
it has created the Miami Miracle a
national model that now drives Florida's
growth all right so here is Francis
Suarez you know an interesting thing
when I was recently down in Florida
a bunch of the people I spoke to who are
sort of like on the Republican side not
sort of I spoke to a bunch of Florida
Republicans many of them are more
interested in Francis Suarez being the
Republican nominee than they are in it
being wrong Des Sanctus they would
prefer Suarez over wrong
um which is interesting but it was I was
in the Miami area so that's obviously
very very biased towards folks in that
area let me bring up something and get
people's thought on it
um oh and before I do that let me make
sure I'm keeping up on thank yous
acrobatic pineapple has just re-upped a
twitch Prime subscription and I want to
say a huge thank you to Jason sickmeyer
for gifting another membership on my
website Ryan Gunter for gifting one and
Stanley minarik for gifting one here's
the deal folks
you can sign up at joinpakman.com with
the code CPAC trash if you want a free
membership from one of these great
people donating them just go to
davidpackman.com free membership and
input your information and then we'll go
through that list okay so
paid membership
don't don't email me but by by the grace
of God do not email me about this
buy a membership at joinpakman.com
request a free one at davidpackman.com
membership okay
um Kenneth says via a Super Chat first
time catching you live Dave love your
videos especially you destroying
Republican candidates last year keep up
the good work thank you very much
Kenneth appreciate that here's what I
want to bring up to you guys okay
I um was talking to someone about CPAC
yesterday off stream
and one of the things they said to me is
if they found out
anybody that they did business with or
or had as a service provider went to
CPAC and as an attendee they would
immediately find someone different now I
think this is interesting because as
I've said before
I uh I mean listen I'm pretty sure like
my accountant is sort of like a Mitt
Romney Republican
uh who has made it clear
he's on the left on social issues but
just like thinks taxes are too high and
okay no problem whatsoever very good
accountant not a big deal fine
um you know dentists tend to be more
conservative than average when it comes
to medical professions my dentist I have
no idea his politics but maybe he's a
republican I don't know okay but if if I
found out
that like my dentist went to CPAC to
like learn you know as an attendee in a
serious manner I'm finding a different
dentist I'll just tell and it's not a
question of intolerance this is a tiny
subsection of the right that is insane
completely and totally insane now
obviously if you're going because you're
in the media or something like that's
different right but what I'm saying is
if you have like a day job where you're
just like you run a car dealership or
you're a dentist or or whatever the case
may be you're like I'm going to CPAC to
learn about it
there's enough of every profession that
I don't need to be doing business with
people who in a serious manner go to
CPAC I I that's you want to call me
intolerant for that listen I have plenty
of friends that are Republicans plenty
of friends disagree with me about what
the tax rate should be or whether we
should have Medicare whether Social
Security is the best way to provide for
retirement all day long folks all day
long but as you know I draw the line at
anti-Semitism I I don't associate with
people that I know to be anti-semitic or
racist or uh uh you know whatever the
case may be
and people who are going to CPAC in a
serious way I'll find an alternative
I'll find an alternative okay yeah and
by the way you know the the fact that
Ben Carson was doing brain surgery uh
it's all a little bit crazy to me
Stanley minarik has just gifted another
membership on my website and Barbara
Cody has gifted one as well that puts us
at 14 today also want to say a huge
thank you to no one who uh no there's no
other twitch subscriptions to mention
let's talk about a few other super chats
Eileen says thanks for the learning you
provide well thank you Eileen I really
appreciate that
megwine says bienvenido Senor love the
stream keep up the good work thanks
megwine I appreciate that this is like
an unhinged panel on Israel which we
will listen to in a moment called the
holy land does anybody know who this is
apparently her name is Viana schlapp is
this like Matt schlapp's daughter or
something I don't know which is what
we're going to talk about tonight today
so David
um what does it mean that CPAC went to
the Holy Land
well first of all it's great to be here
and to be back at CPAC it was very very
special uh that CPAC decided to
prioritize going to Israel Israel is one
of America's best friends and closest
allies in the entire world I want to
remind everybody okay American Jews are
overwhelmingly liberal
the interest of right Wingers with
Israel is almost always rooted in
Christian theology that some Christians
subscribe to about Israel's place in uh
bringing up bringing about the return of
Jesus Christ in some of these uh
doctrines all the Jews die when that
happens in some of these doctrines some
number of Jews are saved this is their
interest American Jews are liberal they
overwhelming it's actually I believe
it's the most liberal voting group other
than black Americans and it's very very
close a doomsday theology some might
call it yeah let's listen a little bit
community and we've seen some hostility
from the Biden Administration uh towards
Israel it's very very problematic so for
an important organization like CPAC to
go to Israel means a tremendous amount
yes so you mentioned um the CPAC
delegation this delegation consisted of
three U.S ambassadors who were all um
greatly helpful in facilitating peace in
the Middle East through the Abraham
Accords so David I was hoping you could
tell us where do the Abraham Accords
stand today
it's a great question so very briefly
the the Hayward records came to happen
because of two main factors one it was
prime minister Netanyahu back so now
they're going to pretend as though the
Trump uh presidency led to any progress
on the israeli-palestinian conflict of
course it did not it is true that during
Trump's presidency for the first time in
a long time there were flights again
between do you guys remember where it
was there were flights between Israel
and like was it Saudi Arabia or where
where were the flights or UAE I don't
even remember
it was such a such a meaningless detail
anybody remember where it was and like
Jared Kushner was on the flight I think
Qatar it was Qatar okay they were yeah
but big picture the Trump Administration
was a complete disaster when it comes to
the israeli-palestinian conflict Trump
widely promised and he meant it that
Jared would solve the
israeli-palestinian conflict during the
during the first four years if Trump's
presidency
didn't happen in case anybody wasn't
aware uh so this maybe maybe one of the
most dishonest panels so far thanks to
Sterling Lana for gifting two more
subscriptions via twitch I really
appreciate that super chat from Bay
photo had schlapp been accused of sexual
assault uh a woman do you think CPAC
would have take such a hit both are bad
but I really think think it comes down
to homophobia so Matt schlapp was
accused of sexually assaulting a man
the question I think is if he had been
accused of sexually assaulting a woman
would it have been as damaging listen I
have no idea I think they're all
pretending that it didn't happen
they all seem to be pretending that it
just wasn't wasn't a thing
um
yeah so after this panel is done
then it will be
um another one on Israel Israel's
democracy versus the Deep State a nice
little as if there aren't enough
conspiracy theories involving Jews
already they're going to have a panel on
Israel's democracy versus the Deep State
and then the big speeches will start
looks like they're running only about an
hour behind today Nigel farage scheduled
to speak at four which is now will
probably be at 4 30 and then Steve
Bannon scheduled for 4 20 will probably
be more like 450. and then Vivek
ramaswamy scheduled for 4 40 will
probably be about 5 10. so that will be
what we're what we've got coming up
today and then tomorrow we will be here
for the Donald Trump speech
um I do have a very very busy weekend of
brunch and uh I've scheduled brunches
around CPAC which is great because I
never have brunch at 4 pm so it actually
works really really well to um
you know to be able to be here tomorrow
for the the grand finale for this thing
how was my chicken chili the other day
yeah the other day I made a white or
white chicken chili and a lot of people
in the chat were saying what does that
even really mean how how can chili be
white and the explanation is actually
really simple no tomatoes and you use
white colored beans rather than red
colored beans I couldn't recommend this
more highly to you white chicken chili
delicious
delicious could it's it's just a perfect
recipe
perfect recipe
thanks to symbolic gamer for re-upping
your Twitch Prime subscription I do
appreciate that super chats continue to
come in how can they hold CPAC while
this country is a power keg I believe
the term is Powder Keg but you know
there are two unrelated things you're
you're allowed to have conferences
really is what it what it comes down to
let's look at a couple of other clips
from earlier at CPAC and see what
happened
um here is Mike Pompeo
let's see what he had to say
we should have won big
I'm happy that we won the house
but we barely captured it
we see inflation gas prices High border
prices we all know these problems others
have spoken about them border prices
what does that mean or a border crisis
but we didn't capture that
we lost three elections in a row and the
popular vote in seven of the last eight
there are many reasons for this but one
of them is I think they've lost Trust
in the conservative ideas and this is
the task that's in front of us well to
put it a different way the country
doesn't like the ideas that's really the
problem and I am convinced we can do it
because we're right
I uh yeah very charismatic so my my
sense is that Pompeo is setting up for a
presidential run
he is almost as uncharismatic as Ron
death santis and I don't really expect
uh the campaign to go anywhere that's my
instinct but maybe people uh will
disagree
um here's a little bit more from Nikki
Haley Her speech that she gave
didn't seem to like that too much
he claimed I'm not in my Prime
in which I responded hold my beer
I'm 51.
oh that's not really funny at all okay
um
here is Lara Trump speaking 50 different
genders and sexualities you got pronouns
it's too much
they've got adverbs they've got nouns
they're talking about prepositional
phrases they're debating the Oxford
comma it's crazy what's happening in
schools these days
50 difference
sexual from a teacher period
wow wow what a what a brave declaration
what a blade Brave declaration at CPAC
Steve Bannon crowns one of his reporters
misinformation Natalie uh come Mo you
can give it
remember the New York The Brookings
Institute the New York Times named War
Room the number one misinformation
this is this is from Madeleine Peltz and
Media Matters here's for matter what do
you think of her
[Applause]
Matt
uh really important thought lead thought
thought leadership happening at uh CPAC
as you can see nod says via Super Chat
white beans are underrated I put a white
bean paella special on our menu and it's
sold out thank you sir yeah you know I
actually don't know with white beans I
genuinely when a recipe calls for white
beans sometimes I get um navy beans
sometimes I get cannellini sometimes
there's all these they honestly to me
they look exactly the same maybe the
size is marginally different I couldn't
do they all is it basically all the same
thing do they all taste the same like
I'll just use cannellini and and great
navy beans or whatever
interchangeably and no butter beans are
bigger that's that's a whole other story
it's basically the same thing right do I
have to worry that I'm actually using
the wrong Bean
I don't have to worry okay good
excellent
uh thanks to Casey girl
Casey girl for uh subscribing via twitch
Prime folks uh welcome in it is day
three of CPAC with Deepak it's so great
to have you here we have so many
important and different things going on
by the way have are people aware of the
Spanish Channel
we have an entire Channel where the
content is in Spanish it's in Spanish
um and you can find it at
davidpackman.com
Spanish davidpackman.com Spanish Mark
David says David packman is the CEO of
vivid Edge media a company of marketers
helping Brands achieve marketing
objectives on YouTube amplify clients
message industry is this a show or a
sale
that that's just their corporate name I
don't know what you're talking about
they're just like that's just the
corporate name I don't know
is this a show this is a show right now
we're watching a show
to be specific I use navy beans they
have a unique flavor that cooks out well
Okay let's listen to a little bit of the
second panel on Israel this one is
particularly conspiratorial where they
will talk about the Deep State
um we'll listen to a little bit of this
but after this is when sort of like the
uh the the real stuff gets going
exciting issues but before we talk about
those issues I know this is a very
biblically literate audience
yeah I'm sure
um by the way thanks to Bernie on a boat
as well as Tiny sir Jen for gifting 10
subscriptions history of the Miracles
that occurred in those books and it's an
ancient story of anti-Semitism and a
miraculous salvation
that the Lord allowed the Jewish people
of the time to to be saved looking at
America today question for my two
panelists here what are some thoughts
you have about Jew hatred today the
United States of Americas and parallels
you see some uh some insights Josh we'll
start with you
yeah so great feedback of CPAC so look I
mean uh our stance when it comes to Jew
hatred anti-Semitism should be clear
unequivocal unambiguous we despise it we
loathe it and has no part of our
movement whatsoever period full stop end
of story and you know I'm grateful I'm
grateful to CPAC and to match slap what
a very powerful statement condemning
Nick Fuentes just yesterday but we've
seen these outbursts just from all
across the Spectrum whether it's the
Ilan Omar on the far left to Kanye West
and Nick Fuentes I'm not even going to
call them the far right I won't dignify
them with that term but wherever it
comes from we have an obligation and
duty to condemn it it is evil and that's
it it's really that simple
excellent
so today anti-sama the most important
kind of anti-Semitism is the
anti-Semitism that makes the largest
number of Jews unsafe and the largest
number of Jews in the world live in the
state of Israel and a political program
even if it doesn't announce itself as
anti-semitic that limits Israel's
ability to defend itself that supports
the Palestinian Authority as it pays for
the murder of Jews that calls for areas
of Jews historical Homeland Judea and
Samaria to be off limits for Jews to be
udenron that is a program that is in
practice this is anti-semiticism typical
nonsense you hear from the from the few
right-wing Jews that there are in the
U.S
about the israeli-palestinian conflict
and it is just disastrous just
disastrous and of course anti-Semitism
it's not a small problem it's a major
problem major major problem and there's
anti-Semitism on the right and there's
anti-Semitism on the left it's not the
same type of anti-Semitism I've talked
about it before all of it is on the
table to be discussed
but these are some of the worst ways to
talk about this issue like Bar None not
even close not even close the crowd by
the way
the crowd has no idea what's going on
they're completely unengaged with these
panels they don't know up from down the
few people that are in the crowd they
and that's partially why it's dangerous
because whatever these people say
they'll be like yeah that's that's true
uh horrible absolutely horrible framing
of the issue thanks to Ron is twitching
who is new member number 30 today
um
am I opening the phone lines okay here's
the deal as I said before if we get to a
hundred members and twitch subscribers I
will open the phone lines either before
the big speeches or after whatever you
guys want really easy to sign up you go
to joinpakman.com okay this is the
website you hit the sign up button you
can do monthly or yearly where it asks
you for a coupon code you can type CPAC
trash because that's what it is and the
discount I'm not even going to say it
out loud because my my accountant would
just be very upset with me
um and our lawyer is not even sure this
is a legal discount it's such a big
discount it might not be legal in some
places so uh I I honestly January and
February were tough months for the show
with everything going on with YouTube
and everything else Obama so I encourage
you to get one of those memberships or
gift one and if you want a free one go
to davidpackman dot com slash free
membership let's do a couple of
voicemails here just as we stand by
um let's see what we've got so David
are finding What God Says to us instead
of the next challenge is I want them to
define God I think that's in all
fairness tell me what does God look like
how do you get this message all right I
don't need you to call me would that I
mean it's not that is not I don't I just
don't know what I can do with that
necessarily but it is an interesting
question it's certainly an interesting
question
um let's see what else we've got here
um
what else do we have a lot of a lot of
very mediocre stuff let's see here hey
David um I want to ask you a question uh
that will sound like a joke at first but
it's okay actually serious and I've
thought about it a lot and I've talked
to a lot of people about it and it makes
everybody really uncomfortable okay so
we have the anti-vaxxers the
anti-masters the anti-science people and
the we'll call them the trumpets and I
think they all kind of are lumped into
this category I like to call
um anti-reality
and uh my question about that is at what
point in 2023
is it okay for family and friends to say
to somebody
you need help and regardless of what you
think of me saying that
we're going to get it for you
um I have stories it sounds like this
caller is talking about are they talking
about committing someone because like
when I hear when I hear you need help
and no matter what you think we're gonna
get you help it sounds to me like you're
talking about an involuntary commitment
to a psych ward and that's uh that's
pretty dicey stuff and to be perfectly
honest I don't think you're going to get
someone committed to a psych ward just
because they have completely insane and
anti-social and sociopathic political
views I just I just don't think a psych
Ward's gonna really take someone uh
unless you can demonstrate they're
really a risk to themselves or someone
else nor do I think that that's really
the way to go so I understand that the
question is being asked in a serious
manner but I'm just not I'm not just not
sure about that
not really sure about that
let's see what else we have as far as
voicemails go in the last few minutes
before the big speeches start
uh let's see here hi David I just want
to make a couple of comments one I love
the secure cold mustache that you're
growing and it just cracked me up even
more when you said that you were doing
it as a joke because my ex-husband and I
when we were obviously still together he
um grew a satirical mustache and nobody
understood the joke except us so I don't
know if that made the whole thing better
or what but it was just funny well it it
led to he being your ex-husband so I
don't know how well it went right and
then my other
bar so
our sub-time Watcher for a long time
loved him and religious and yeah
basically I've had to tune out from him
about maybe a year ago he just got way
too hyperbolic on the wokism stuff and
it was just it became a big turn off for
me so I just I tuned out I mean he is
still a good advocate for democracy so I
guess we haven't like completely lost
him but his views on certain things I
don't think they you're right they
haven't changed necessarily but it just
the change in dynamics of
what's going on right now and then the
jokes like he's still making the trans
jokes that it's just cringy and
um that thing with Jake Tapper when he
like actually said that like trans
people are like asking for too much
right now and I'm just like dude what
happened to you in some ways it's all
weird anywho um again I love what you do
keep doing what you're doing and take
care bye all right yeah I appreciate
that thank you very much I I can't
really add anything to that quite
frankly I mean that uh that's
very very much well said stands on its
own in a very very powerful way thanks
to M4 Olive ingamund and gay Dragon for
the twitch Prime subscriptions also huge
shout outs to the great Eileen Smith as
well as Zach Blake Eileen and Zach each
just signed up on my website with the
coupon code CPAC trash it is trash and
as soon as this event or this speech is
over we are next going right into the
big speeches including Nigel farage
Steve Bannon and Vivek ramaswamy I know
Vivek ramaswamy one of the most Electric
Public speakers I've ever come across
and I expect we will all be very very
titillated by that
um let's see what else we have here from
the standpoint of voicemails
hello David yes I'm looking for a quick
way to earn a lot of money
um if you have any ideas feel free to
share them on the show or the bonus show
um
yeah I'm in a hard financial position
right now I only have 4 500 to my name
um a 4600 actually but uh yeah anything
you can say will help I watched the
finance Channel but I don't really talk
about get rich quick there
um all right thanks bye yeah I don't
have any uh get rich quick ideas for you
I'm sorry my one idea is start a podcast
and YouTube channel and work really hard
at it for 10 years and if it's still
around after that you'll be doing fine
that's that's really the only
um the only advice I have
hey David it's Eric from math man you
must be shaking in your boots I can see
your visibly visibly scared you can tell
that uh the walls are closing in they're
going to figure out all the lies that
you said everything you say is a lie
yeah I might end up in jail soon
propaganda the virus was a hoax the
entire time you force people to get
vaccines told them that it was the best
for them they're dying everywhere that
hcq and Ivermectin didn't work hcq and
Ivermectin didn't work that's all true
the whole thing and now they're coming
out the fauci what are you going to do I
mean your time is limited I I wouldn't
if I were you just some friendly advice
I'd shut it down and beat the
scene you know that's the best best you
can hope for you probably got a few
million bucks why don't you go back to
uh Argentina or uh you know Argentina
Canada
I would like to go it's hard to go to
you know hide out
you know it's going to be subject to
like tyt and that dummy Jesse Gollum uh
dollar less and all of them because this
is really funny yeah I you know it's
I think Eric from Mass is right I think
this may be the last live stream because
the indictments are probably coming down
on me really soon because I suggested
you know
following Health guidelines I guess
thanks to Mike seal who just signed up
at joinpakman.com with the coupon code
CPAC trash thank you very much sir I
appreciate that let's see if we can
squeeze in another voicemail or two
um in the last few minutes before we get
to Nigel farage
uh
let's see what we have here
a lot of really wacky wacky voicemails
um
how about
okay here we go
transgender and what they want to do in
Texas
um
and there was one
I could mention because I was sitting
with a friend and she said to me it'll
never happen in America
and and I said
I can remember of History besides
slavery
is after Pearl Harbor the Japanese
American
were
they were put in camps true they lost
their businesses they lost their homes
they had to stop over again after they
were released but yes America has not
been kind to a lot of people thank you
and I enjoy watching you all right well
there you go no I don't think any
response necessary there
uh you guys want to hear do we do we
want a hit of Whitney just to see what's
on Whitney's mind
[Music]
uh French people chose to be shorter is
that it's like okay we'll see how the
Jewish people get like set up for
everything eleventh kind of like a
little bit like French they have French
genetics and they're like probably
almost like maybe a little bit taller
the French people chose to be shorter
that I have never heard before
I have never ever ever heard that ever
but anyways I just
just the general here in America for
women who
are married and having sex frequently
um it's like they make it super obvious
too because when a couple isn't like
having sex it's like uh they're
unprotected or something it's like man I
don't know what is going on with Whitney
but
it all sounds pretty crazy Danielle ball
has just signed up on my website with
the coupon code CPAC trash I believe we
are now getting into
the prime time of CPAC day three based
on the latest schedule let's even
refresh the agenda just so we can make
sure we've got the latest one this is
for Friday
so we are standing by now yeah same
thing still Nigel farage coming up next
one of the most anticipated Steve Bannon
and then Vivek ramaswamy will be
speaking so we are watching all of it
all of it all of it all of it how do I
sign up for twitch Prime oh boy not this
uh if if you've got Amazon Prime okay
you get a free twitch Prime subscription
every month you've just gotta link
Amazon to Twitch and then you can
subscribe for free with twitch Prime
that's like sending us what we call
Bezos bucks it should be pretty
self-explanatory it shouldn't be um
shouldn't be a very very complicated
thing
let's see what else we have in the very
limited time before what I think is
going to be Nigel farage's speech unless
the schedule has been changed
um
let's see here hey David just want you
to know that you're a sexy
I appreciate your opinions and your
commentarian what's going on oh wow and
I also hope that you're uh buying
Bitcoin
um Safe Haven right now and uh that's
how you protect yourself bye I have not
been buying any more Bitcoin no that I
that I have not done all right it's
propagandist Steve Bannon let's see how
bad this gets
[Applause]
thank you
you know I'd like to be able to report
that we're just in a crisis or there's a
crisis coming but that's not the case
there's no longer a gathering storm the
storm is here oh no
the storm is here this is the most
dangerous time in world history since
the late 1930s early 1940s and how do we
get here
our Bettors our Elites let us here step
by step by step this is what you have
now this is Maga conspiracy red meat he
knows exactly who he's talking to he's
of capital markets and economics
and a crisis of geopolitical and
Military in the converging very rapidly
and then they're going to conflate and
once they conflate they're going to spin
out of control and it's anybody's bet
now remember we came off of on 3
November of 2020
four years of peace and prosperity
three November of 2020.
the interest rate
the interest rate the 10-year treasury
at in the evening of three November when
Fox News illegitimately called it for
the opposition and not Donald J Trump
of which of which our nation has never
recovered
of which is never recovered the interest
rate and tenure story was 0.8 percent
0.8 percent today for the first time and
God knows when the entire structure of
our interest rates from one month
treasuries to 30-year treasuries went
over four percent yeah you should see
what my high yield savings accounts are
yielding it's a beautiful number not
take those type of interest rates you
will be absolutely crushed and the
people crush the most are the
Millennials that now have nine trillion
dollars of debt
they are going to be Russian surfs
they're not going to own anything with
no possibility of owning anything
Professor rabini just told us about
about the financial aspects of it we're
going to have recession inflation
stagflation depression debt crisis
Doctor Doom who called 2008 said it's
only going to get worse because the
world's got 30 trillion uh 300 trillion
dollars of debt so I got that now let's
talk about the United States right what
do we have 32 trillion dollars that
that's nothing the CBO reports you're
going to have another 20 trillion
dollars of debt in 10 years you're gonna
be paying a trillion dollars a year in
interest payments it's not sustainable
who got us here
well Joe Bon yeah but he got here
because of the compromise made by The
Establishment Republicans in the Senate
this is the exact type of stuff that
Trump did in 2016 people have no clue
what Steve bannon's talking about but it
just sort of like sounds like he's
making sense and he's like kind of
pointing out some issues nobody has any
clue what he's talking about nobody
could understand if you afterwards went
to the crowd and said okay explain the
mechanics by which the things Steve
Bannon said work they couldn't explain
it to you the interest we pay off any
Securities that come due we never
default in the debt ever we pay off
Social Security and Medicare and then we
have to have a conversation right we
have to have a conversation it's not an
easy conversation all the easy decisions
of decades ago
now on top of that this converges right
this converges on the geopolitical
situation look what happened since Trump
left office you have the ayatollahs in
Iran right tell us how how safe do our
allies in Israel feel right now
Trump got out of the Iran nuclear deal
has nothing to do with Biden Trump got
out of the Iran nuclear deal merger of
the KGB in the CCP you
turn of one you have our great allies in
Saudi Arabia already already taking and
transferring oil to Chinese currency
away from the US dollar
Trump likes erdogan and the radical
Jadis in Pakistan you have a conversions
on the Eurasian land mass and what are
we doing we're turning over our foreign
politics of zelinski to let him
determine whether he's going to go take
Crimea or not
this guy is genuinely dangerous like
it's it's not it's
he's he's genuinely dangerous uh trying
to the only thing we can hope for is
that the CPAC crowd isn't smart enough
to really even understand what he's
saying hey oh well they won't help us on
the on the Wuhan lab you know maybe we
need help he's in Ukraine
he's in Ukraine yelling yelling goes to
Ukrainian man he's really out of breath
is she going to go to East Palestine
Ohio she goes to Ukraine the convergence
of these two crises is going to lead us
into a third world war a third world war
that are not only going to wipe you out
economically and financially in this
country more important your sons and
daughters are going to die on foreign
battlefields are you I remember we were
told Joe Biden will immediately get us
into Wars and we're more than halfway
through the first term he hasn't gotten
us into Wars now remember what he's
talking about right is defining Wars so
I guess he's got a little under two
years to get us into one of these wars
um
prepared to fight back are you prepared
sit down and just take it understand
this is a criminal grifter okay I'm not
that's not I'm not that's not a
pejorative he is a convicted criminal
grifter you're too lazy and you're too
disconnected watching television
watching the bread and circus of modern
culture to care is that true Biden got
us out of a war he's like oh I need any
day Biden's gonna put us in a war oh
what he got us out the neoliberal neocon
system globally is underwritten by you
your taxes your pension money the
insurance money and most importantly
your sons and daughters you're the one
that can tell Congress hey not one
increase to the debt ceiling and we want
to see massive Cuts we want to see
massive Cuts in spending and we want to
see it now not next year don't give me
some happy talk formula don't give me
some set of mathematics I want to see
real cuts big massive now when you talk
about real cuts and rust votes put it
out the president you know Biden is
always running around talking about it
two trillion dollars in cuts
over the next 10 years thinking in
Medicaid these are going to be tough
Cuts okay they get the woken
weaponization I don't think it's
everyone's gonna be a fight a tough
fight but think about it for a second we
have to cut trillions of dollars
out of our budget every year to
accumulate to trillions of dollars over
the next 10 years everyone's going to be
ugly right
we're given 200 billion dollars to
Ukraine we're paying their pensions
we're paying their health care to people
under 35 do you have pensions that the
government's paying for right now
you do not do you have full health care
you did they're against those sorts of
Pensions and by the way the amount of
money that's being spent in Ukraine is
such a small amount of the U.S budget
it's just uh such a deceptive way to
even talk about this and he he's gotten
himself so worked up he's out of breath
and the Europeans are going to pay for
it we've paid enough in the wars in
Europe we're not a European power we're
a Pacific Power
uh-huh
they don't know what they're clapping
for
I need them on Capitol Hill in a Wall
Street in the city of London to hear you
can I hear you are you going to send
your sons and daughters to this war
and this what war is this again this is
a room of Patriots that have served
their country
now let me tell you where the hard part
gets the hard part gets we've had the
oligarchs on the Republican Party the
big hedge fund guys making 16 billion a
year Ken Griffin and Mitch McConnell and
Rupert Murdoch they have Dean hey they
no they have told you that Donald J
Trump is not going to be the president
United States
when don't fall don't fall off the
primary stuff you have you have really
good and decent people Governor DeSantis
Mike Pompeo Tim Scott yet you have Nikki
Haley that's all fine it's not relevant
we don't have time for on the job
training for a man that gave us four
years four years of peace and prosperity
oh my God
lunacy lunacy
show me show me what Ken Griffin has
given us show us what Mish McConnell has
given us show us what the Murdoch's a
bunch of foreigners have given us what
have they given this country nothing
Donald J Trump let me repeat in a very
volatile time in American history gave
us four years of peace and prosperity
and you know why
you know why he put you in the room to
make decisions out of the room after the
deal and Trump not only puts you in the
room he puts you at the head of the
table the average person was a Forefront
in Trump's mind when he made decisions
and that's why they hate him they don't
hate him they don't hate him because
he's Trump they hate him because he
represents you he gives you a voice and
he will not back down
[Applause]
look at look at look at Fox News look at
Fox News the president announces his uh
this is historic a guy gave you four
years of peace and prosperity and now
she's going to run again after having it
stolen in broad daylight of which they
participate in they don't even they
cover it live for 20 minutes and then
they say if there's anything newsworthy
we'll cut back and they go to some panel
and some discussion note to Fox Senior
Management When Donald J Trump talks
it's newsworthy
oh my God
what what happened in the first week of
January you had Matt Gates and bobert in
the Magnificent Six that stood there and
put it all on the line and what did Fox
News do they rolled out Coal Grove and
the hatch from the Bush Administration
that got us in this Mass to say we need
Unity we need Unity to come look turn
we're not looking for Unity we're
looking for victory this is really
dangerous really really dangerous
we're not looking for a compromise we're
looking to save our country we are not
what they mean by unity as you to give
up and you to roll over this is how you
get 32 trillion dollars and dead going
to 52 trillion dollars in debt this is
how you get your kid to die on foreign
battlefields in Iraq and Afghanistan and
now in Ukraine that's how you do it and
what's up Biden got us out of
Afghanistan and he wants to pretend
Biden's a warmonger is not simply a
leader of a political party he is not a
politician he is a leader of the most
powerful political movement in America
history
okay Murdoch here's the way it's going
to be brother
you've disrespected Donald J Trump long
enough okay he goes to east uh Palestine
and gets to buy Administration it's a
global news event and you don't cover it
live is there that much happening on Fox
News at 2 in the air to call Trump
bringing Trump water to the derailment
and going to a McDonald's is not exactly
global news any
that brought peace to the world for four
Chinese let off a bio weapon right
wouldn't you think to have respect for
the audience you would have him back up
here to talk about the geopogos what if
you had respect for people would you do
that
well he'll be up tomorrow expect you
read the depositions the deposition they
have a fear a loathing and contempt for
you and you're the ones that can make
changes the shareholders if you want
your share price to stay up you need to
take action the first thing you need to
do is get rid of Paul Ryan as an
independent director
hahaha
delusional
if Paul Ryan's saying that Trump wins
he's not going to go then you got to get
rid of him the Murdoch's immediately
have to start covering president Trump
no no special deals just cover the man
asking the tough questions but we need
to hear the voice of Donald J Trump we
do
hey
an old man Murdoch while you're at it
why should no more softball interviews
to the guys running against him and no
more infomercials okay play it straight
you play it straight Donald Trump's
going to win the primary and Donald
Trump's going to win the presidency
all right let me leave you with what
Trump is up against he's not up against
DeSantis or Nikki Haley or Mike Pompeo
he's up against Ken Griffin and Mitch
McConnell in Murdoch okay they have
deemed if he wins the primary they're
going to work for the Democrats just
like they work for Hillary Clinton I was
there I can tell you they were in
Clinton's Camp the entire way all they
are is about money and the only people
can stop him on the face of the Earth
are you you and you mega mega mega
remember
Murdoch
you've deemed Trump's not going to be
president well we've deemed that you're
not going to have a network because
we're going to fight you every step of
the way
wow
big Fox News at times
if your task and purpose is to take your
country back this country will be saved
all right so Fox News a big Target of
Steve Bannon lumbering off stage visibly
struggling for breath saluting the crowd
which is delivering a standing ovation
things that they mostly didn't
understand or will certainly have
misheard in retrospect really fine
really firing them up
um as you can see
an extraordinarily dangerous speech
and also very interesting that he is uh
wait is that Bannon coming back out
what's going on here
oh no it was okay uh
okay I don't know why that ended that
was really weird
this entire stream just ended so we'll
switch over here I believe Nigel farage
is coming up next what an insane insane
event folks unbelievable truly
unbelievable
um let's get phone lines open when we
get to a hundred members we'll open
phone lines be it before or after farage
thanks to Jared walking and JD Riley for
the twitch Prime subscriptions welcome
to Mary Thai and here is farage coming
out right away let's listen Dave what a
lovely welcome
good afternoon see back
do you know when I first came and spoke
here it was in 2012 and I was the only
non-american Foreigner on the stage what
about the American foreigners all of
that worried me because I think that our
two countries have a heck of a lot in
common
but I come back to CPAC today in 2023
and you go through the coffee rooms and
the bars and you meet people here from
Japan where CPAC has events from
Australia where CPAC has events from
Hungary where CPAC had its this is one
of the least serious people out there
France from Spain from Italy from all
over the world and this conference this
annual conference of CPAC has now become
has now become for the entire
conservative movement across the Free
World this is now the epicenter and it
is an amazing tribute to Matt a
mercedes-lap to have achieved that it
really is
it really really is
now
not for the first time in my life
I find myself today
in a bit of trouble
with the UK authorities
you see a story is broken overnight
a lot of WhatsApp messages have been
leaked between the Prime Minister senior
officials who were overseeing
lockdowns
mask mandates
vaccine mandates
the people that took charge of our
country and the story that's broken
overnight and here it is
I went to Tulsa in the summer of 2020
for Donald Trump's first rally on the
campaign tour
and I did that because I'm a friend of
his I did that because I believe in him
I did that because I think he's just
about the bravest man I've ever met in
my entire life
trouble was
coming back from Tulsa
under bizarre Draconian lockdown rules
it meant I had to quarantine
at home for a fortnight Obama now
what was a fortnight what was 14 days
did it include the day that I'd landed
back in the United Kingdom and I was
presented with a dilemma
because For the First Time in months
the pubs
are Great British pubs
which have been closed for all that time
the pubs were opening
well I did the anything I thought I
could possibly do
I was there at 12 o'clock
in the morning knocking on the door
saying let me in what a funny guy I want
to get back in the pub
not just because I enjoy a beer but
because every Pub is a parliament it's
where we have free speech and debates
question each other make up our minds
anyway they let me in I had a drink the
one or two CEO photographs things out on
social media
but it turned out
that I hadn't actually been in the
country for a full 14 days
even though 8K been tested him a day
before no I'd been there
I think for 13 nights and 12 hours
and it led to the leader of our Liberal
Party writing to the police well worse
than that what we've learned overnight
is that Matt Hancock who was our health
secretary
absolute pipsqueak of a loser but never
mind really interesting story he has
quite a way with words I mean sort of
chap if you were employing him you
wouldn't even let him wash the cars in
my view but never mind
as a Hancock's group are talking to each
other
and they're saying because of what I've
done that I'm a pub hooligan
now you know you can call me what you
like I'm not a hooligan but they
actually in these messages say they want
to get hold of our home Affairs
Department because they want and I quote
to lock him up
to lock him up I mean listen the these
are people who call for all sorts of
people to be locked up who haven't even
been accused of doing anything wrong so
why would that be a big surprise to him
in the name of Coronavirus
governments
State governors in America
took away from us Liberties and Freedoms
that had been built defended fought for
over generations and over centuries we
gave unlimited power to people to lock
us inside our houses to tell us we
couldn't visit our elderly relatives to
tell us in our case we couldn't even
play golf or go fishing no we had to do
what big government told us to do ladies
and gentlemen is what tyranny looks like
yeah
on the back of this I've admitted today
that I also broke lots of other lockdown
rules
yeah
I went to meet my elderly parents
often outside in a safe environment
sat in the garden had a barbecue had a
drink I went fishing you see the point
is this
when laws become enemies of men
men the point is he doesn't have
anything else to talk about other than
personal anecdotes of what he did during
covid oh
however
if any government ever tries to take
away my limiters again like that I'm
going to be a rebel from day one and I
suggest you join me in that
now this day
in some ways
these are very difficult times for
conservatives in the English-speaking
world are they you guys have to be frank
it's all well and good saying we won the
house
the midterms were a big disappointment
true
we need to look in the mirror and
acknowledge that
in other parts of the English world the
conservative movement's in real trouble
go North to Canada
[Applause]
someone just yelled Castro about Canada
you know I was just up there
I don't think so what he did to the
Canadian truck is was beyond
comprehension people who would
accidentally live their lives within the
law found themselves outside of the law
and in the end their bank accounts were
closed we can go to Australia
which has now become Paul part is on
Earth
we can go to New Zealand
but hey there's some good news Mussolini
Jacinda adarn has gone that at least is
a bit of good news
how we can go to the UK
where the conservatives were elected
with a massive majority much of which I
literally gave them on a plate
elected as conservatives they've
governed as liberals we're tied to Net
Zero and a whole bunch of lunacy and yet
in Europe
conservatives are making real progress
they're making real progress in France
they're making real progress in Spain
they're making huge progress in Italy
for those just joining us this is not at
least overtly a comedian
not ashamed to say
the Georgia Maloney
is my new pet up no question about it
so why
is conservatism doing well
in a non-english speaking world and as
badly as it is in our world I'll tell
you why it's what comes from the West
Coast it's what comes from Big Tech it
is the dominance of those companies in
the English-speaking world that have
spread this poison through our systems
I'm hoping and praying
the Elon Musk taking over Twitter starts
to redress some of this balance pray
harder my friend I will say
but these are depressing times for
conservatives
just this week is this that really dry
British humor I've heard so much about
case
of a drag queen
invited to speak to a group of 11 year
old children 11.
boys and girls of 11.
being told there are 73 different
genders
girls being told lock them up they can
take a part of skin The graft of their
skin from their arms
to make a male Implement that's about
the most diplomatic way I think I can
possibly put that
and a kid in the class says my mummy and
daddy tell me
there are two genders there are men and
women and a kid of 11 is kicked out of
the class
and you know you know if you've got kids
or grandkids going through the
university system
they're not even being taught critical
thinking objectivity
[Applause]
so it would be easy
for this audience in the wake of a
disappointing midterm in the wake of the
catastrophe that is the southern Border
in this country in light naturally a
British guy would come here to talk to
us about the Border it
and to think we're losing
and maybe we've lost
maybe we've lost everything
the judeo-christian principles upon
which our civilization were founded are
under attack the belief the belief that
the family is a good thing and a good
unit in which to bring up children is
viciously under attack
we can easily get down and depressed
I'm going to tell you why
you shouldn't get down and depressed
because whoever dominates mainstream
media whatever you read in the New York
Times if that's what you choose to do in
your free time
whatever you see on CNN or elsewhere
the truth is
there is still in America
and across the Free World there is still
a mainstream majority for common sense
for decency it's still there
you ask Americans
about her ID 75 of Americans support
voter ID 50 of Democrats support voter
ID you ask most people about our Roots
our family they agree here's why we can
win
in Scotland which if you haven't been is
one of the most beautiful countries in
the world it's part of the United
Kingdom
of course Donald Trump's mum
smart to explain that to this crowd
Scotland which is part of the United
Kingdom for the last few years they've
been under the rule of a first Minister
called Nicola sturgeon
she wanted Scotland to become the most
Progressive country in the world and
started passing crazy legislation and
then a few months ago
she passed a new gender recognition Act
where kids of 16
without reference to a doctor
without any parental consent at all kids
of 16
could change their gender
legally change their gender
eighty percent of Scots didn't want it
but the Scottish Parliament pushed it
through and then
a legal case occurred
a man a really bad guy who committed two
rapes
turns up in court for his trial
wearing a wig
tell him a judge him a jury that he's
now a woman
gets a long prison sentence then all the
judges were wearing wigs too and so no
one cared
which clearly endangers women and
suddenly that pendulum that's gone that
way for all those years has swung back
Nicholas sturgeon has now resigned as
first minister of Scotland
the CPAC crowd is really keyed into
Scottish Politics as you know
[Applause]
found in Scotland against a woman with
that huge level of power can you turn it
round in this great country of the
United States of America can you turn
this round
okay I can't hear you can you turn this
round
will you turn this round no good well
save America and you'll save the free
world and I love you and thank you very
much indeed thank you
there goes Nigel garbage potentially
today's last speaker although it might
be Vivek ramaswamy who had an explosive
launch to his presidential campaign a
load of absolute yes that's
exactly the way I would describe it that
is exactly how I would describe let's
listen to how fired up these people are
you know day one kicked it off
we're excited it's just getting started
day two okay so um we're going to keep
an eye here to see if it is indeed over
or Vivek ramaswamy is going to be
speaking thanks real quick to people who
signed up during that insane tirade of
dangerous authoritarianism and unhinged
disinformation Nature Boy braided Dragon
79 carleo as well as Jared walking
thanks to Barbara Cody and Daniel Bean
who signed up on my website as well as
Linda wood Miller really appreciate all
of that support that may not have been
that may not have been the end for today
according to the schedule we are still
supposed to be hearing from Vivek
ramaswamy like now-ish so we'll keep an
eye let's see well there's a right way
you can do it and that's to diversify
your account and that includes putting
Gold Silver and precious metals silver
we're gonna put some silver in your in
your pockets
um otherwise if they are done then I am
going to be back tomorrow we will have
the um culmination of this entire
Insanity with failed former president uh
Donald Trump of course everybody knows
who I'm talking about President Donald J
Trump yeah exactly
um conservatism is the Blind and
fear-filled worship worship of dead
radicals said Mark Twain via Super Chat
says love it when a foreigner says what
they want they eat it up absolutely you
know if if Nigel Nigel garbage showed up
and said things the CPAC crowd didn't
like they would be saying why are you as
a foreigner coming here and telling us
anything about what we should be doing
or what's been going on or why who how
dare you they would be saying if it just
didn't happen to align with what they
want but alas
that's not the case
um do we know if it's over or a Vivek
ramaswamy is still going to speak today
it's really really difficult to narrow
it down to one but I will say I was
really excited by the lineup having
people like uh Laura Trump or even
having others they even had Nikki Haley
up there today speaking to everybody and
there was a whole thing with that but
they really did have a very interesting
lineup and it's always neat to see
everything I'm very excited for tomorrow
though particularly well of course two
speeches one president Trump but James
O'Keefe is going to be speaking tomorrow
too imagine being excited for that all
right so it is over this is the end of
what was supposed to be day three but
like day one just kind of imploded so
they didn't even really have it so
they're calling it day two needless to
say uh this was what was going to be day
three tomorrow is day four the final day
we will have uh let's see so let's go
back here and click on Saturday
so Trump is speaking
at 5 25 so it'll probably speak at 6 30.
he'll probably be about an hour late so
I'll probably kick it off at 5ish 4 30
or 5. there is some interesting stuff
earlier like if it weren't all spread
out I would cover the Lauren bobair
speech I would cover pillow at 240 jair
bolsonaro I would cover Tulsi I would
cover
um you know there is stuff I would
certainly cover but it's too spread out
and it's a Saturday and a lot is going
on so I'll probably start at fiveish and
then we'll review highlights or low
lights from everything that happens
earlier and then I think we'll we'll be
in pretty good shape as far as coverage
goes so if you watch today thank you
um make sure you're following on Twitch
make sure you've liked on Facebook make
sure you've subscribed free on YouTube
so that tomorrow God willing you'll be
notified that I am live again
see everybody then
he's going to represent you long and
hard
and we will ban men Obama